putting mental health as a top priority  that is the mission  at one of the amazon warehouses right  here in the valley  they've created a booth for employees to  take a moment for themselves called  amazing  inside there are videos on breathing  techniques calming sounds and  aromatherapy  our amazon booth allows the associate to  have privacy  so our warehouse is very busy this is an  environment that  allows them to have quiet which in  day-to-day life  sometimes is very challenging so by  entering this booth they can engage in  those benefits that we have amazon says  as more employees returned to work it  was important to provide other resources  after the year we've been through